we all know that Hamas has been
designated uh a terror organization just
like many other Terror organizations
have had this designation like the proud
boys here in the United States now Sunny
host has gone in so deep on on the
absolute dishonesty and the obfuscation
of the truth and everything else here
she is listen to her uh not only just
lying about Israel but listen to the way
she speaks look at her body language the
way she's looking she doesn't even
believe her and and that's how
so many of these people operate they
repeat the nonsense that they don't
believe and by the way Sunny the Hamas
guys they wouldn't be thrilled with
someone like you
either no I just I you know I look at
this from a legal perspective and I
think that we all know that Hamas has
been designated uh a terror organization
just like many other Terror
organizations have had this designation
like the proud boys here in the United
States um but I but I do think that what
we need to remember is that there is is
an international human rights body of
Law and when you look at that law part
of it is
retaliation against innocent civilians
collectively is also Terror and is also
a war crime and again those are not my
words those are the words of the law and
the president of the European commission
Ursula vandan said just last year when
we were all talking about Ukraine she
said Russia's attack act against
civilian infrastructure especially
electricity or war crimes cutting off
men women children of water electricity
and heating with winter coming these are
acts of pure Terror and we have to call
it as such you are a human Act of Terror
you clown first off the way the coldness
with which she talks it's so obvious
it's not that she's just so deep in in
the abyss on this it's just so
absolutely crazy again we've Illustrated
repeatedly that Israel is not trying to
kill civilians they're going out of
their way the double War crime the
warning people Hamas keep keeping people
but also this idea she there's something
called the law and this is this is I
would actually say this is a this is a
symptom of a disease of the western
liberal mind there are people trying to
kill you trying to kill everyone you
know who want a world that is in no way
connected to a world that you want to
live in or have lived in and you're
going well we've got a piece of paper
here I've got you see I wrote this down
and someone in Brussels signed it and
said we've got ways that we're supposed
to behave D you're not allowed to just
behead and burn children I have it on
this oh I got a paper cut you see it's
it's
absolutely bananas she's an idiot she
knows she's an idiot you think Hamas or
any of these people care about
international law so you're making
civilized people play by rules that the
people who are literally beheading them
would never play by it's so absolutely
insane on top of the fact that she tried
and even as she was saying it and this
is how you know this is prepackaged
nonsense and this is put out there by
ABC intentionally when she went out of
her way to say that Hamas is has been
designated a terrorist organization the
Imp the implication she's trying to say
is that it's not really terrorist they
they were designated to beheading people
but they were design just like the proud
boys right the proud boys as far as I
know have not beheaded anybody or burned
couples together or held any hostages or
anything else anyway Matt from the daily
wire he commented on that I thought this
was pretty good if you put aside the
fact that the proud boys have never
launched a military offensive and
slaughtered hundreds of innocent people
and if you put aside the dozens of other
crucial differences then yes the proud
boys are pretty much the exact uh pretty
much exactly the same as Hamas great
point just profoundly
ridiculous